(upbeat music)
- Hi, I'm Hannah, you're
friendly neighborhood wine mom.
Tonight we're drinking some
red wine in a mini bottle
that's really fancy 'cause
it has a twig tied onto it.
There was a comment on a previous video
asking what's the worst parenting advice
I've ever gotten, and that's pretty funny,
so I figured I'd tell
you guys the three worst
pieces of parenting advice
I've ever gotten in my life.
So let's go right into it, after a sip.
First, sleep when the baby's sleeping,
and I know so many moms
get this piece of advice.
It just makes no sense.
Should I do laundry when
the baby's doing laundry?
Should I pee when the baby's peeing?
Should I do dishes when
the baby's doing dishes?
I'll just take a long nap
while the baby's sleeping,
and do the rest while they're
helping me out with it,
because that works out just great.
When the baby is sleeping
is what I like to call
get shit done time.
That's when I do everything I couldn't do
with a baby in my arms.
Try vacuuming with a baby in your arms,
and they're scared of the vacuum.
They're not cooperative people.
So instead of sleep when the baby sleeps,
how about you volunteer to come clean
while the mommy sleeps?
I think that's a better
piece of parenting advice.
Next, I get gold all the
time that holding you child
too much will spoil them.
I don't think it's possible for your child
to get spoiled off of physical contact.
I'm pretty sure the only
thing that's gonna spoil them
is giving them too much
stuff that's undeserved
and letting them get away with being
a jerk without consequences.
The whole point of a parent
is to care for and comfort
your child, so if I'm not
picking them up when they
wanna be held, what am I here for?
Me picking up my child when they're hurt
or sad or feeling bad
is only gonna make them
feel more secure with
themselves and therefore
be a better person.
I feel like this advice comes from a time
when parents were a lot more
distant from their kids,
and it was kind of like I
don't wanna deal with that.
And now we're in a time where
parents wanna deal with that.
I want to be there for my children.
I want to be their source of comfort.
So to give me that advice is nonsensical.
And last, people say that
you should teach your kids
to use non-anatomical words
for their private parts.
They think you should make up like a more
kid-friendly word for it, like oh my gosh,
I hurt my wee wee.
That's just super weird.
My friend's daughter got
sent home from school
with a note asking her to
stop telling her daughter
to say vagina and instead
to say down there.
That's just so weird
because, to me, down there
means anything from
the waist down, so like
when I say down there, I could
mean legs, shins, feet, toes.
When you use the actual word about it,
it clears up all the mystery.
It's not this foreign
thing that you can't say
the actual word, like Voldemort.
Everyone in Harry Potter's
like, my God, don't say
Voldemort, but when you
actually say it, it's like,
oh, that's who he is.
That being said, I was
raised with the idea
of not saying anatomically correct words,
and to this day, I get
extremely uncomfortable
using the words penis (laughing)
I'm an adult.
I'm gonna teach my kids the correct way
to say their privates.
That's just how it's gonna be.
Penis. (laughing)
That's all I've got for today.
I'm Hannah, your friendly
neighborhood wine mom,
and if you've received a worse
piece of parenting advice,
leave it in the comments,
because I gotta see it.
In the meantime, I gotta get on Facebook
and start telling other people
how to raise their kids,
because it's really important
to do that as a parent.
Till next time.
Ask what's the worse paren huh huh.
When I try to talk fast doesn't
work when I'm drinking wine.